[Applaudissements]
parce que tel on verra bon alors ça m'a
peut-être foot y'en a marre c'est que
pour gallas
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous arrive cyril hanouna
recueille que thébaux est la raison gens
me dit quelque chose
qu'est ce qu'il ya mal de pays
chalabrais persie d'être avec nous il
est 20h12
ah oui quand même
asap mais quoi pas comme ça non pas
comme ça non non
merci aux téléspectateurs de nous
rejoindre dans touche pas à mon poste
le magazine de l'adar cas en attente
elle ce soir à 20h12
je n'ai pas envie de rire idol - tu l'as
fait des progrès la gueule
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce soir j'ai envie de marcher marcher
marcher
georges klein pas maritime à gaston
[Rires]
bardot je viens d'apprendre une nouvelle
1 à munich re poursuite il m'a glacé
leçons et vous aussi chez vous je vais
demander à tous ceux qui nous regardent
aller chercher leurs amis leurs ennemis
leur concierge leur quartier de leur
gardien leur médecin leur voisin
j'ai envie que tous ceux qui nous
regardent et je demande au public de le
faire se lève et se prennent tous par la
main
c'est quoi ces conneries et fait pas
j'aimerais que vous prenez tous les
mains ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu
aquatique les mains au crabe là tu
voudras appelle faire avec moi
j'aimerais que tout le public et les
mains en crabe j'aimerais que les
chroniqueurs et les invite également ya
un chronographe riz se prennent les
manques rappelons que la note à coeur
regarder ça va ce soir
aujourd'hui je ne verrai plus jamais les
choses de la même manière car ce soir un
séisme s'est abattue sur le paf
ah oui pas et je viens de nous
demanderait qu'une chose oui faut que je
vous dirais la nouvelle ah oui je vous
demanderai de terre je vous demanderais
de ne piper mot
en résumé mme otis s'arrête
ah oui quoi oui dans cette phrase il y
avait un indice un double sens
non c'est pas pipé c'est vrai en plus si
vous nous rejoignez 20h15 la nouvelle
vient de tomber et quoi
fait peur
allez dos que sa barbe cette fois c'est
quoi ouais je ne prends pas ça pas comme
ça
[Musique]
allez je vous le dis quoi et coiffé tout
voir clave ou non mais moi j'ai peur du
chocolat l'avocate chier mais ces plans
du football
j'ai déjà fait chaud c'est comme ça et
on va d'accord allez quand même bon
qu'est-ce qu'ils mirent cet état ce qui
met dans cet état
[Musique]
si thierry beccaro arrête moi tu cela
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'ai envie de demeurer les
boules
non mais youtube france télévisions
s'était arrêtée ccc c'est de vivre non
mais moi j'aime beaucoup thierry nous
aussi ah non je suis là alors
franchement mathieu et merde c'est dans
ces moments là qu'on a besoin d'un ami
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention à la boule noire
[Rires]
alors on rigole mais c'est vrai c'est
une nouvelle incroyable avec moi tu sais
que keep france télévisions